[Music]
fires
rage for thousands of kilometers
they spread across the landscape
consuming grasslands and fern forests
alike
ahead of these relentless blazes life
large and small
flees in thundering herds or scattered
and dropping from the air
desperately screeching alarm an eerie
permanent twilight claims the sky thick
with dust without the heat from the sun
temperatures plummet and the global
winter descends
freezing solid the lush forests that
escape the burn
and depriving the remaining food chains
of the vegetation they need to survive
this is the kt extinction event
aftermath of a catastrophic asteroid
impact that left a crater
150 kilometers wide and deep enough
to contain mount everest twice over
from this millennia-long night there
would be
no dawn for the dinosaurs
life hangs by a thread
[Music]
when the dust finally clears and the sun
shines once again
it does so on a largely empty world
with the big dinosaurs gone only the
hardy scavengers and survivalists are
left
some dinosaurs did make it through those
for example that could eat tough
long-lasting nuts and seeds or which had
a soft fluffy down to protect them from
the cold
scavenging mammals too clung on who we
used to scraping through
on short measures it's a scorched
battered
frozen post-apocalyptic landscape
but for them it's a world of opportunity
suddenly in little more than the blink
of an eye the predators are gone
the competition is wiped out and the
resources of the entire globe
are theirs for the taking with the
deadly hunting pterosaurs
now gone the skies no longer threaten
sudden swooping death
so the fluffy nut-eaters can roam and
climb in safety
they can even learn to fly themselves
without danger from above
eventually their fluff evolves to
feathers and their beaks are specialized
to their food source of choice they
become the wildly successful
avs birds of which there are tens of
thousands of species
flying running and even swimming all
over the globe
meanwhile the mammals once very much the
underdog in a world ruled by terrible
lizards
now have the run of an empty home as the
plants of the plains and forests grow
back
without competition they have the pick
of the crop
they can eat more grow larger change
their lifestyles to nurture their young
rather than endlessly looking for food
there is now
more than enough energy available for
the mammals to support carnivores
and even apex predators they
expand into habitats all over the globe
wherever food is to be found
even into the oceans in the few million
years after the kt extinction
mammals diversified more than in the
preceding 160 million years
but of course this was not the first
time a catastrophic event had
revolutionized
life on the planet some two billion
years earlier
the great oxidation event the largest
extinction of all
time brought life to the brink
and when it bounced back it too was
fundamentally
transformed indeed without the first
extinction
life may never have made it beyond
simple bacteria
at all
[Music]
before the kt extinction that wiped out
the dinosaurs before even the end
permian extinction
known as the great dying there was
another mass extinction that almost
wiped out all life on earth
around two and a half billion years ago
at the fringes of
thriving microbial communities some
groups had evolved to use
photosynthesis instead of chemistry to
acquire their energy
these new photosynthesizers could
colonize everything the light
touched but the gift of photosynthesis
came with an unwanted by-product
oxygen which in the archaean ocean was
as lethal as mustard gas
deadly oxygen had filled the oceans and
then the air
the reactive element poisoned everything
in its path and then
transformed the atmosphere stripping it
of its insulating blanket of methane and
plunging the planet
into an ice age for 300
million years thick ice extended from
the pole to the equator
and along the shallow shorelines
photosynthesizers
died in their droves the architects
of their own destruction
[Music]
but we know that this wasn't the end of
life on earth
our very existence on the surface of the
planet today is
testament to life's tenacity through the
most catastrophic
events indeed the vast majority of our
ecosystems today
rely on the very photosynthesis that
brought about such destruction
life clung on by the thinnest of threads
just one percent of all life in arcane
oceans persisted into the next age
the proterozoic and it's from this one
percent
that the living world was rebuilt
after the dinosaur decimating kt
extinction the dust cleared on an empty
world
and so too after the great oxygen
extinction the one percent of life that
survived
did so in isolated refugia perhaps where
volcanoes punched through the ice
like in iceland today the warmth of
magma so near the surface maintained
shallow water oasis in the midst of a
vast ice
desert small communities of
photosynthesizing bacteria
could cling on here in their own lonely
worlds
some more ancient bacteria survived too
the anaerobes still feeding off
hydrothermal minerals in deep
dark ocean crevices as yet untouched by
the toxic
oxygenated waters unaffected by the
persistent darkness
perhaps for them the great oxygen
extinction and ensuing ice age
had passed by unnoticed as long as
tectonic forces maintained their supply
of volcanic minerals
and the poison gas didn't reach them it
was business as usual
for these ancient chemotrophic bacteria
these isolated communities persisted
where they could
and the volcanic activity that helped
keep them alive also
helped bring the ice age to an end
untroubled by the rise and fall of
bacterial civilizations at their feet
volcanoes continued to erupt explode and
effuse
carbon dioxide into the atmosphere
gradually an insulating layer of this
greenhouse gas
built up and the atmosphere could once
again trap heat
and warm the surface eventually after a
seemingly
unshakeable winter the ice receded
patches of blue ocean emerged and grew
and the warmth they absorbed
helped to chase the ice back to the
poles
[Music]
the surviving life forms witnessed as
the planet uncleared itself
casting off the chains that had gripped
it for so long
they emerged from their tiny warm oases
into oceans
of untapped riches but these oceans
were empty just as the post-dinosaur
diorama would be
only the lucky few remained to enjoy the
spoils of this post-apocalyptic world
for those that had already survived the
worst this empty world was a gift
of opportunity it took little time for
the shallows to become colonized once
more
as the ice melted sea levels rose
drowning the shorelines of every tiny
island
and making brand new habitats for
opportunistic
sun loving microbes photosynthesis was
still an ideal source of energy since it
required only the inexhaustible glow of
the sun
and ubiquitous carbon dioxide
and as is the natural way of things
microbial predators evolved too
to take advantage of the energy captured
by the producing photosynthesizers
instead of capturing the sun's energy
themselves they consumed the green
producers
and extracted the energy contained
within their organic
structures but with such riches in store
and an entire planet as their playground
the survivors had the chance
to innovate further just as the fluffy
feathered dinosaurs learned to fly in
the safety of a rich
empty world so too could the microbial
survivors
figuratively spread their wings
in the late 19th century imperial
germany is a hotbed of science and
innovation
young inquiring minds are drawn to the
university of bonn in the west of the
empire
palatial buildings scattered along the
banks of the rhine
set in expansive grounds each home to a
dedicated institute
and hundreds of focused scholars in a
small
overfilled office in a corner of one
such institute a
finely dressed young man adjusts the gas
lamp on his desk
pulling it closer to the microscope
before him
the man's name is andreas schimper and
he
is a phyto-geographer tasked with
understanding the distribution of plants
all over the globe although on this
evening in 1883
his mind is troubled by revelations more
microscopic in nature
shimpa is an adventuring naturalist like
so many of the men in his
family at the tender age of 27 he has
already taken steamships across the
atlantic to venezuela and the west
indies
traveling to the corners of the globe in
the late 19th century was a thrilling
and dangerous affair
and andreas schimper has a taste for
botanical adventure
his exploration and research will give
rise to the term tropical rainforest
and many species of plant will come to
be named in his honor
but andreas believes that to truly
understand the nature of an exotic plant
one must study it at the smallest
possible scale
and so he spends hour upon hour pouring
over paper-thin
slices of his specimens staring at their
box-like
cells and the green speckled
chloroblasts inside them
he sees this same fundamental
organization in every green leaf
he places beneath the objective whether
lovingly returned from the venezuelan
jungle
or plucked from the lawns of his own
institute
chloroplasts and their surrounding cells
each distinct but their fates
inextricably intertwined
did this come to be shimper has a theory
but it's almost too outrageous to
consider he pauses
with his pen hovering above the paper
and slowly
begins to write
[Music]
back in the proterozoic ocean playground
life is rosy for the photosynthesizing
bacteria
they have resources in abundance and all
the resistances they need to survive in
this brave
new oxygenated world but other survivors
of the great oxygen extinction
are still struggling anaerobic bacteria
still shrink from the damaging
reactive oxygen and are still dependent
on the chemical energy sources that have
supported them
for the last billion years perhaps gene
transfer could have been their savior
once the same gene transfer that allowed
the knowledge of photosynthetic pathways
to be shared among microbial communities
at the beginning of the great
oxygenation but these anaerobes have
been separated from their oxygen loving
sisters for hundreds
of millions of years and the rift is too
wide to be crossed by genetic trading
alone
but that's not to say that they can't
benefit from each other in a different
way
in the bountiful world of the
proterozoic these two
disparate groups do something
extraordinary
they cooperate
cooperation in the living world is
commonplace today
if you know where to look on the african
plains
small dowdy birds spend their days
perching around
and often on the large game that roam
the savannah
they are ox pickers and the clue to
their lifestyle is in their name
they live among rhinoceroses zebra and
other large mammals
and feast almost exclusively off the
insects they find on the mammal's backs
in this way the birds get an easy meal
and perform near constant
pest control in return this kind of
symbiosis where both parties benefit in
some way
occurs time and time again in the animal
kingdom
coteries of cleaner fish hover around
the bellies and open mouths of deadly
sharks
eating dead skin parasites and cast off
food
the service they provide renders them
immune to the shark's attention
and they are protected in turn by their
ferocious patrons
mutualism even extends between animals
and plants
as flowers adapt to attract insect
pollinators producing sweet nectar to
draw them in
and using them to spread their sex cells
to every other flower the insect may
visit
the symbiosis between bacteria the dawn
of the proterozoic
was a springboard for survival in the
brave new
oxygenated world but its origins are
somewhat sinister
in the basic food chains of the
microbial past some
anaerobes acquire their energy from the
organic molecules of their oxygen-loving
cousins
they engulf them whole swallowing them
as a snake might consume an entire deer
to digest it slowly over many days
but in a one in a billion chance
occasionally the prey
isn't digested but continues to live on
inside the predator's cells
the predator doesn't get the nutrition
from the meal it swallowed but it gets
something even
better the fruits of its praise ongoing
labor
in a sense the consumer has enslaved its
prey inside itself
keeping it captive and taking some of
the energy it releases
for its own
but the relationship isn't so one-sided
although it may seem like a diminished
existence the prey microbe actually has
been transported
into a life of luxury protected from
environmental stress and the threat of
further predation
the bacteria that lives inside another
is infinitely richer than one struggling
along
in the outside world this is the most
intimate of symbiotic relationships and
eventually
they even learn to grow and reproduce
together
soon this so-called endosymbiotic
relationship
becomes a permanent one with the two
irreversibly reliant
on one another indeed this relationship
persists to this day
in practically every cell of our own
bodies the engulfed bacteria have become
our mitochondria the powerhouses of our
cells
which take the sugars we eat and break
them down to release energy for our
metabolism
our mitochondria even still retain some
of their original dna
distinct from the dna of the cells
themselves
but endosymbiosis was such a successful
trick
that proterozoic cells found use for it
a second time
the newly paired endosymbiotes could now
break down organic matter in an
oxygen-rich environment
allowing them to quickly rise to
dominance throughout the oceans
a second pairing between these new
dominant chimeras and successful
photosynthesizing cyanobacteria
changed the playing field once again
through the same process of engulfing
preserving and protecting the
endosymbiotes acquired the
cyanobacteria's ability
to capture the sun's energy to make
their own
organic matter with this new
relationship
the trinity transcended the cell
could survive anywhere on any food
source
or on the sun's light alone
the photosynthesizing endosymbiotes
become the chloroplasts
the photosynthesizing organs in the
green cells of algae and plants
today
[Music]
this was the revelation that the
phyto-geographer andreas schimper had
in bonn in 1883 he had little evidence
beyond
the ubiquity and likeness of
chloroplasts in plants from around the
world
but their resemblance to tiny
free-living cyanobacteria was too great
to go unnoticed
yet this was outrageously new thinking
indeed charles darwin's concepts of
evolution were still controversial
and hotly debated amongst natural
scientists of the time
he opted for a tentative footnote
writing of the chloroplasts he saw
their relationship with the organism
containing them would somewhat suggest
a symbiosis his ideas were pursued by
scientists throughout the 20th century
and endosymbiosis
is now widely accepted as the origin of
an entire domain of life
the eukaryotes
all plants animals and fungi are
eukaryotes and are made from an entirely
different kind of cell
to the bacteria that ruled the archaean
oceans
they contain the mitochondria and
chloroplasts of the original symbiosis
but also a self-contained nucleus and
other cellular machinery to help
streamline an increasingly complex
existence
it's likely that only an event as
catastrophic as the great oxygen
extinction could have created the unique
conditions to allow this remarkable
transformation to happen
and create complex cells capable of
supporting the next stage
of evolution on earth
[Music]
some 100 years before andreas schimper
sat musing over the chloroplasts in
exotic plants
another naturalist was putting pen to
paper to express his own
novel thoughts on botanical matters
his name was erasmus darwin and he
was grandfathered to charles darwin a
talented medical man from a wealthy
english family
erasmus spent much of his life working
as a physician in litchfield england
but he was a natural philosopher and a
poet at heart
choosing to express his ideas through
elegant verse and florid prose
so it was that in 1789 erasmus darwin
penned a poem
called the loves of the plants which
personified the parts of a flower
specialized for sexual reproduction as
an amorous bride
and groom but erasmus also uses the poem
to put voice to his own views on the
purposes of sex
in the plant kingdom he asserts that the
romance between flower bride and groom
the joining of pollen and egg after
successful pollination is the very thing
that creates new types of living thing
and is the source of evolution
and of progress erasmus darwin was among
the first
to consider sex and evolution together
and unwittingly hinted at a process
whose genesis
lay two billion years deeper in time
the empty world following the great
oxygen extinction laid the foundation
for the emergence of eukaryotes
but the newly oxygenated proterozoic
earth
was no paradise although the archaic
bacteria had largely evolved a
resistance to reactive oxygen
neither bacteria or novel eukaryotes
were entirely
immune in fact 2 billion years later
even we
are not immune to its slow chemical
attack
oxygen inside the cell gradually attacks
chemical machinery breaking down
large complex molecules like dna this
so-called oxygen toxicity is one of the
reasons that our bodies begin to break
down
as we age our cells are gradually
damaged by oxygen over our
lives to the point where they can no
longer effectively do their jobs
this of course had never been a problem
for anaerobic archaean bacteria
but in an increasingly oxygenic world
the risk of toxic oxygen became one that
could no longer be ignored
bacteria reproduce in a simple way an
individual clones its dna
and splits the cell in two producing a
sister daughter clone
identical in every way to its parent but
if oxygen
damages the dna of the parent then the
daughter
inherits that damage unchanged over many
generations the oxygen damage acquired
over individual lifetimes accumulates
and grows until even a simple cell can
no longer function
the lineage of clones is doomed
this was the fate that befell probably
the most famous clone of all
dolly the sheep dolly was cloned from a
six-year-old sheep in 1996
genetically identical to her sister
mother dolly died at just six and a half
despite her breed having a usual
lifespan
of 12 years she had developed diseases
associated with old age having inherited
the oxygenically aged dna
of her mother in a sense she was already
six years old when she was born
and the first eukaryotes put themselves
at even greater risk
through the house guests living within
them mitochondrial symbiotes need oxygen
to release energy from food
and chloroplast symbiotes actually pump
oxygen
into the cell as they perform
photosynthesis so eukaryote not only had
to survive in oxygenated waters they had
to survive the toxic oxygen within
themselves
in the name of adaptation they had
invited the killers in
through the front door those that had
survived the great oxygen extinction
now faced a slower but no less terminal
fate
thanks to the ongoing attack of oxygen
so another extraordinary
evolutionary innovation was needed to
ensure
the survival of the survivors
that innovation
was sex
in modern animals and plants sexual
reproduction is a complex affair
with specialized anatomy and instinctive
behavior to ensure the continuation
of the species take for example the male
black widow spider
who must walk into the jaws of death
just to approach his mate
to avoid being mistaken for prey he
performs a
curious dance vibrating his abdomen at
just the right frequency
the female knows not to eat him straight
away allowing him to approach
and complete the act before eating him
after all but sex on the cellular level
is little more than a modification to
the dance already being done
by bacteria worldwide instead of copying
the entire genome and cleanly splitting
a cell in two
the eukaryotes copy just half their dna
and create sex cells much smaller than
themselves
thus depleted these sex cells cannot
survive alone
but must join with another from another
individual
to complete the sequence and make
themselves whole once again
fully restored the daughter is therefore
a blend of two parents
rather than a clone of just one
by complicating reproduction in this way
requiring two parents to make new life
rather than just one
the early eukaryotes won themselves
vital protection against the toxic
oxygen in their cells
chance determines which section of dna a
daughter will inherit from her two
parents
and there's a good chance that those
sections will be as yet undamaged by
oxygen
for her the new generation the oxygen
clock
is reset
the risks posed by oxygen over time are
so great
and the protection offered by sexual
reproduction so complete
that scientists believe eukaryotes could
simply not have survived without the
invention
of sex today 99.99
of all eukaryotes from single cells to
the largest of multicellular animals
reproduce sexually to be a eukaryote
is to have sex and that link was likely
forged right at the beginning of
eukaryotic history
in the brave new world revealed after
the oxygen extinction and so
erasmus darwin in his modest english
townhouse in the 18th century
was unknowingly peering through two
billion years of history
as he considered the courting dance of
plants
sexual reproduction is the source of
variation in all living things
and right at the beginning that
variation was critical
for the survival of an entire domain
when erasmus looked around him he saw a
world dominated
by multicellular eukaryotes all
eukaryotes are dependent on the oxygen
machinery inside their cells
and the sexual reproduction that injects
variation
into every generation all this
was made possible by an apocalyptic
event more than two
billion years previous the great
oxygen extinction just as we can thank
the kt
extinction for our mammal lines
dominance over the dinosaurs
so we can thank the oxygen extinction
for the diversity and dominance of
eukaryotes across the globe
it took extraordinary strife to produce
the extraordinary diversity
we enjoy in the world today
[Music]
even the darkest nights end letting the
sun rise
on a world of new opportunity
you've been watching the entire history
of the earth don't forget to like and
subscribe
and leave a comment to tell us what you
think thanks for watching
and we'll see you next time